digamos que quieres contar los días
después de tu último cumpleaños por lo
que un día después pones una marca en el
muro al siguiente día pones otra marca
en el muro un día después de ese pones
otra marca en el muro y en este momento
puedes preguntarte cuántos días han
pasado desde mi cumpleaños pues vamos a
contar las marcas 123 3 días después de
tu cumpleaños podríamos pensar que estos
símbolos que están aquí representan al
número 3 y continúas otra marca otro día
otro día otra marca y continúas así y
así poniendo marcas en el muro
de hecho esta es la forma elemental de
representar números representarlo con
marcas y continúas
y después de haber acumulado todas estas
marcas te preguntas cuántos días han
pasado así que cuentas 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 todas estas
marcas que están aquí representan 17
días
y día tras día continúas escribiendo
marcas pintando marcas en tu muro
y los días pasan y pasan y pasan
y sigue exponiendo marcas en el muro
pero un día te preguntas cuántos días
han pasado y te das cuenta que empezar a
contar todas estas marcas empieza a ser
una tarea bastante difícil y te
preguntas existirá otra manera de
representar el número de marcas que
tengo en mi muro y lo primero que habría
que hacer es contar cuántas marcas
tienes vamos a contarlas
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29
30 31 32 33 34 35 36 37 38 y piensas no
sería una buena idea agruparlas de
alguna manera y te viene a la mente
tienes 10 dedos qué tal si los agrupamos
en grupos de 10 y conservamos las
unidades que no hagan
de 10 a ver vamos a hacerlo entonces
vamos a contar aquí tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10
entonces este que está aquí es un grupo
de 10 continuemos tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 aquí tengo un segundo grupo de 10
sigamos tengo 1 2 3 están estos 3 luego
voy con 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 perfecto aquí
tengo un tercer grupo de 10 y finalmente
tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 perfecto tengo 3
grupos de 10 y 8 unidades el primer
grupo de 10 segundo grupo de 10 tercer
grupo de 10 y luego 8 unidades y
simplemente por haber hecho esto tenemos
una manera más fácil de contar porque
ahora simplemente decimos un grupo de
diez dos grupos de diez tres grupos de
diez y después 12345678 tres grupos de
diez y
así que decimos tengo 38 38 y en el
fondo así es como funciona nuestro
sistema de numeración nuestro sistema de
numeración decimal que utiliza 10
dígitos los dígitos 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y
9 y nuestro sistema de numeración nos
permite escribir todos los números de
una manera muy cómoda utilizando solo
estos 10 dígitos muy bien si quisiéramos
escribir el 38 que tenemos aquí lo que
tendríamos que hacer en nuestro sistema
de numeración sería escribir un 3 que
corresponde a estos tres grupos de 10
escribir un 3 en la posición de las
decenas
y después escribir 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8
unidades en la posición de las unidades
y así tenemos 38 y como sabemos cuál es
cuál lo que sabemos en nuestro sistema
de numeración es que la primer posición
corresponde a las unidades este que está
aquí son las unidades
y la siguiente posición a la izquierda
está que está aquí es las de las decenas
y luego vendrá en la posición de las
centenas y los millares eso lo vamos a
ver en otro vídeo
y esto que tenemos aquí nos dice
exactamente lo mismo que tenemos de este
lado las dos cosas son equivalentes
veamos aquí me dice tres decenas que es
lo mismo que tengo aquí una decena dos
decenas tres decenas y ocho unidades 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 es decir podemos escribir lo
de esta manera vamos a hacerlo esto es
igual a escribir tres decenas vamos a
poner los tres decenas tres
más vamos a tomar el color de las
unidades más 8 unidades
muy bien
y utilizando el mismo sistema de
numeración este que tenemos aquí podemos
reescribir esto como que son tres
decenas pues tres decenas son treinta y
ocho unidades pues son ocho osea que
sería treinta más ocho todas estas
representaciones que tenemos aquí es el
mismo número en diferentes formas de
representar
y con suerte esto te ayuda a apreciar
las virtudes que tiene nuestro sistema
de numeración que de una manera concisa
podemos representar números a diferencia
de este sistema de poner marcas en la
pared que es muy difícil representar
números en especial si pensáramos en
números grandes por ejemplo en 1.057 eso
sería muy difícil de manejar y nuestro
sistema de numeración nos permite
hacerlo de una manera muy cómoda